being under 30 and building a biotech
company is not sexy it's a kind of faux
pas honestly and it's just been very
fun learning how to
modernize
an old industry
i'm saying hollywell i'm the founder and
ceo of a company called loyal we
developed drugs to extend dog lifespan
and i am 27 years old
so i grew up in austin texas we had 15
cats like two or three dogs she used to
rescue animals the picture of me was a
little baby squirrel on my shoulder
which looking it's really cute but
looking at it now see that's a total
rabies risk
so i'm definitely a huge animal person
but actually the reason why i started
the company was the summer before i'd
gone to college for art school i decided
to do an internship at a neuro-oncology
clinic
and i basically just kind of realized
that we don't actually in my opinion
have free will i met a number of
relatively young brain cancer patients
who there was something anybody anyone
could do for them so really like ever
since i was since i was 18 i've been
trying to understand what's the best way
to work on a problem right so i was you
know pre-med student for a while then i
started a phd then i worked at a venture
fund investing in biotech companies i
ended up going to dogs first about two
years ago because i basically realized
that there was a huge unmet need
especially in the case of larger dogs
but also the dogs were a really awesome
proving ground for potentially getting
the first ever drug approved explicitly
for aging and then translating we learn
from dogs over to people
i struggled for a while because i'd walk
into a room and people wouldn't assume
that i'm competent i don't know if it
has to do as much as me being under 30
as me being a woman i think that's
really been a big variable in that so
you have to believe that you can build a
dog aging drug that it's a billion
dollar market that this is the best way
to get to human aging drugs that there's
an aging drug for human markets and that
i can do it i'm competent my team's
competent and we can execute
we're questioning the variables that
have been set for a long time and that's
allowed me to build this really amazing
team around this really cool idea in a
period of time that has been quite rapid
you